khloe kardashian's quarantine can be
summed up in three words fitness TP and
Tristan on Tuesday the mom of one hit up
her insta story to share her morning
workout routine and it's safe to say she
goes all out beast mode yeah that's Koko
running uphill with her two-year-old
daughter true sitting in a wagon that's
strapped to the reality stars waist
[Music]
bible I'm mad impressed and also
exhausted just looking at her I'm a
beast in the gym yes you are Queen and
while people are living for Chloe's hot
fit fierce mom workout people aren't
loving her latest quarantine prank so I
haven't had this much excitement in
months that's when I come out - so what
Mason and Koko do when you're the
sleepover it's actually genius yep
kourt's ten-year-old son Mason and Chloe
toilet papered the hell out of courts
lon
Hey look at this what do you think about
it well next time guess what we're gonna
do pee people were quick to call out
Chloe on social media calling the move
selfish and wasteful given that there's
a shortage of toilet paper right now
after the world started panic buying it
in bulk
during the corona virus pandemic
somebody got our house
toilet paper I'd last night one person
tweeted stores are limiting one pack of
toilet paper per customer when there's
any in stock meanwhile Khloe Kardashian
is tp'ing her sister's mansion while
another called the prank completely
insensitive and utterly ridiculous you
get the point
people no likey on Monday Chloe showed
off a massive and I mean massive balloon
display she received from her ex Tristan
Thompson for Mother's Day I love it the
two have been quarantined together with
their daughter true and in the
mid-season teaser of the family's hit
reality show fans caught a glimpse of a
pretty interesting zoom convo between
Chloe Kim Scott Disick and Kris Jenner
the subject whether or not Chloe and
Tristan have had sex in quarantine okay
just a little refresher the two split in
February 20 19 after his cheating
scandal with Kylie Jenner's former
bestie Jordan Woods you know things
happen and of course I'm sorry and
apologetic as much as I can be but now
Chloe and the NBA star seemed to be
super focused on co-parenting their baby
girl
it's hard work for all parties and I
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you shared children
with people and that's how it should be
and Coco is putting herself and her
daughter first I'm just super happy and
content and I'm focused on work and like
taking care of me my body and soul and
true
[Music]